[Musique]
même si la nouvelle Jeanne d'Arc pèse
son poids
la statue est creuse
d'où cette question au moment de la
finition faut-il la consolider avec une
armative
parce que après
s'il fait comme ça
toujours comme ça
Louis XIV tous un armée à l'intérieur
les bras
c'était jeune c'est les bras alors j'y
vais
[Musique]
impossible de faire tenir une statue de
2 mètres dans un four alors il faut
mouler séparément les différents
éléments et les assembler
peu à peu le sculpteur retrouve la
vision d'ensemble et les détails d'un
corps qu'il a étudié pendant un an avant
de passer à la phase de fabrication
Boris Lejeune sculpte toujours les corps
nu avant de recouvrir de vêtements et ça
lui seul le voit mais d'un peu rejeter
un peu voilà c'est
ça
le doigt comment elle est fixée là en
consciemment il y a plus de présence
plus de présence de
certaines vérités dans tout tu vois par
exemple ça là ici là ça c'est des
défauts de fonderie là tu vois mais
finalement voilà parce que le moins tu
touches et le mieux comme là on voit que
ça on peut l'enlever il y a pas de
problème
cette Jeanne d'Arc presque parfaite avec
les petits défauts faisant son humanité
doit ensuite passer la dernière étape
qui va lui donner sa couleur définitive
la patine
toutes les gammes de couleur de du rouge
au bleu toutes les gammes
les patines à froid nous on fait
principalement des patines à chaud parce
que
on a un résultat immédiat donc c'est
avec le chalumeau c'est donc une
oxydation artificielle avec le pinceau
les produits chimiques la couleur se
fait pratiquement immédiatement en
fonction de la température
après c'est le serrage qui est aussi
important et après c'est fini
c'était début 2020 une Jeanne d'Arc
flambant neuve s'apprêtait à sortir de
la fonderie pour prendre la direction de
Saint-Pétersbourg où elle est
aujourd'hui installée
mais le covid puis la guerre n'ont pas
permis d'organiser les cérémonies que
les financeurs du projet espérait